Facebook CEO Mark Zuckerberg
congressional testimony could have a big
effect on the tech leaders of tomorrow
Tony de copal watched yesterday's
hearing at founders space in San
Francisco where Steve Hoffman helped
support startups they were joined by
Chirag Bhatt of the office collaboration
platform flock and chris kelly who runs
sir vada an online survey company Tony
is in Woodside California Tony good
morning good morning and welcome to
bucks of Woodside this right here is a
traditional Silicon Valley power lunch
spot there's a table right here I want
to show you Tesla according to lore had
some of its early meetings here not far
from this location we've got the booth
where hotmail was founded and the big
question now is what company is gonna be
here next well according to the
entrepreneurs we spoke to that's got a
lot to do with what Mark Zuckerberg does
right now
who believes Mark Zuckerberg is sorry oh
I think he's sorry he has to testify in
front of Congress yeah he's definitely
sorry about about I mean just having no
idea of where his information is getting
all the information that he's supposed
to be I responsible for he's being used
I don't hear anyone saying he regrets
the error
he regrets the consequences if
Zuckerberg truly was sorry that this was
going to happen then in advance he would
have made it a policy of the company and
to really put the consumer above profits
and he didn't do that Mark Zuckerberg
may deflect the attention of Congress
but there's no ducking the judgment of
other tech executives these guys who we
met at a San Francisco workspace also
rely on data to build their businesses
do you buy the idea that data is the
most valuable resource on the planet the
fuel the future I do i buy the data is
the new oil trend it's actually you know
it's even harder to I should to control
that oil you can actually see data you
cannot some people have referred to the
data economy as in effect surveillance
capitalism accurate yes we're gathering
as much information as possible about
every user on the internet and that
information is being used to not only
watch people but influence them predict
what they're going to do
change what they're gonna do all of that
all three are open to the idea of
regulation if it restores trust but not
if it stifles innovation Silicon Valley
wants to make sure young companies get
the same chance Facebook has had to put
their data to use are they a monopoly in
this period of time right now in social
networking they are monopolies but that
monopoly will not persist forever now
Zuckerberg for the record says he
doesn't feel like he has an monopoly
none of the entrepreneurs we spoke to
our direct competitors with Facebook but
everybody out here is competing for that
next big idea because get this by 2025
then uh the number of interactions we
may have with connected devices could
jump from a few hundred to today from
today to 4,800 by 2025 Gail I believe it
thank you very much Tony